coronavirus perhaps the biggest crisis
our country has faced for a generation
what do you make of the way the
government has handled things so far and
just before answering that and on the
back of Rosanna's interview I just think
we should note the enormous debt of
gratitude we owe to our NHS frontline
staff have been absolutely extraordinary
to everyone working in the NHS and to
the care is paid and unpaid who are
bearing the brunt of this crisis so I
just wanted to to say I think the entire
nation is looking at them and saying
this is the best of what we have to
offer as a country and we should be very
grateful to them and look this is an
unprecedented challenge and there's I
don't want to be in a position of
offering criticism of the government I
think they'll be working as hard as they
possibly can they're doing everything
they can they will be mobilised in the
entire resources of government I think
and I offered this not as a criticism
but as constructive advice in my view it
is all about getting to mass testing as
fast as possible because we have to know
who has the disease and who has had the
disease in order to get the lockdown
eased and get people back to work and
get some semblance of normality back
into our daily life so I think the only
thing I would say is for me this is
right from the very beginning it's been
about of course organizing the NHS to
respond to this crisis but the issue of
testing both the PCR tests to say who
has the disease and the antibody tests
to say who has had it and who therefore
may be immune to it these are the
absolutely crucial things I think and
it's interesting isn't you say that
could be one route out of the lockdown
because obviously people been talking
about a potential vaccine but do you
think that if this mass testing is
rolled out not just to NHS staff but to
ordinary people as well that could be
the more realistic way of easing the
measures well I think it's the only way
of easing the measures ultimately
because look obviously the NHS frontline
staff come first in in testing but what
what is the conundrum of the coronavirus
crisis the conundrum the dilemma if you
like is that only a small number of
people are actually in the end going
have a life-threatening version of it
but a small percentage of a very large
number is still a large number and
that's why it's absolutely right that
we're taking the measures of social
distancing and the lockdown
but in the end the vast majority of the
population will be capable of going back
to work and will either be have had the
disease and ramune or have had a milder
version of the disease or won't get it
at all but the problem is unless you
know who's had it or who has it and
those that don't then it's very hard to
see how you you you return to normal
life because your risk obviously is as
you start to ease the lockdown how do
you then deal with any resurgence of the
disease and this of course is what
they're now dealing with in in China and
South Korea and elsewhere but unless you
have that testing capability that you
can apply it's scale and by the way when
I say mass testing I mean I actually
think you will need to get to the point
where you've got the capability and I
assume you're preparing for this now of
testing literally a very large
proportion of the entire population and
you may have to do those tests two or
three different times because you need
all the time to be able to track what's
happening with the disease to learn
where for example there may be a surge
or a hot spot of it and take immediate
action and what kind of percentage of
the population are you talking about
well I think you'll be talking about
virtually everybody I mean this the
problem with the the corona virus is
that it's obviously highly contagious
and although it's true that some people
will suffer no symptoms at all I mean if
you look at the studies coming out of
Italy China Iceland Korea Germany large
numbers of people are what we call
asymptomatic in other words they don't
experience any symptoms the majority of
people who get it will get it with a
reasonably mild version but
unfortunately there's a minority who get
it severely and if you get its ability
then it's obviously life-threatening and
you're posed you then impose an enormous
strain on your healthcare system to deal
with it and that's why it's completely
right as the government's doing and
Michael Gove is explaining you've got to
close things down in order to flat
the curve get on top of the disease but
then as you ease from that how are you
been at ease from it unless you have a
very clear understanding of who's got it
and who doesn't and that's why I think
you will find that round the world and
this is by the way another reason why
it's so sad you'd heard of greater
global coordination on this you'll need
to have the capability with the test
which as I say are not just for the
people who have it but for those who
have had it right and therefore will be
immune to it at least for this cycle you
can have to have that capability now you
were saying there that most people may
just experience mild symptoms of the
virus one of those people who appears to
be experiencing mild symptoms is Boris
Johnson and testing positive for clave
at 19 he's now leading the government's
response in isolation from his Downing
Street flat and as someone who was a
prime minister for a decade do you think
it's feasible to run the country
effectively from your living room well
you can do I mean look you we've got the
technology to to be able to link people
up I mean I've been because my Institute
is working with countries around the
world and we've repurposed the entire
Institute for our teams that are in
country to work with governments there
so I'm having virtual conversations
online conversations with people the
entire time now it's perfectly possible
to do that that depends how how illy is
but if I and again I offer this not as
criticism because I really think
everybody in government will be doing
everything they possibly can but I think
what you find in these situations I went
through a much much milder thing with
foot-and-mouth disease and my Institute
also work throughout the a bola crisis
in in West Africa it is always around
logistics and procurement what you find
in these situations is that you get
bottlenecks not about what you think you
should do because you can usually work
that out but how you do it how you
source equipment how you get supplies
how you make systems move fast and the
only thing I would say on that and it's
really the Prime Minister's perfectly
able to direct this I provided his
health is has not deteriorated but it's
really about how you put the most
capable people in charge of those
of logistics and procurement and I think
the other thing we should be doing right
now by the way is putting everything we
can behind technology and innovation
there will be a thousand things that
technology can help us with particularly
when we need to get the data as to who's
had it and who hasn't had it how for
example when we start to get back to
work and you're trying to trace people
when you may get an outbreak how you
managed to trace all the people they've
had contact with I think there's a
there's a mobilisation of the private
sector alongside the public set here
that is important and might and as I say
I offer this just from my own experience
dealing with these things you sometimes
find that the best people on this are
not to be found in the public sector but
in the private sector for example people
who do procurement logistics that's what
they do for a living every single day I
think mobilizing all that effort is also
going to be important and one other
thing we shouldn't forget this is a
global crisis and by the way if any
country in this crisis and some of the
poorest countries of the world where
we're trying to help at the moment and
whose health care systems will be
completely overwhelmed by this disease
if any country in the world is not over
this disease then all countries are at
risk and this is the classic situation
in which a global pandemic means if you
don't have global coordination and
global solutions then everyone is
affected I want to talk a little bit
about that point that you make and it is
of course the global crisis and every
country potentially could be affected
here how concerned are you about what
coronavirus would mean to countries for
example in Africa right so my
Institute's got partnerships with
roughly 15 16 different governments in
Africa including of the largest
countries there and you know I'm seeing
firsthand from the conversations I'm
having with presidents and with others
in the World Health Organization you
know we've got a huge challenge I mean
an unprecedented challenge but these are
healthcare systems that are already
quite weak and government systems that
aren't all was as effect
they need to be they've got a massive
shortage of equipment ventilators
protective clothing masks testing of
course and in the end if these countries
and they're just at the beginning of the
curve now if these countries aren't
helped at this stage then it's going to
slow down the ability of the world as a
whole to get over this crisis and I
still think in a round global
coordination I don't quite understand
why why there isn't there aren't streams
of work going on where scientists are
coming together to make sure that we
develop the vaccine as swiftly as
possible and industries are being
brought together across the globe so
that when this vaccine is is found and
manufactured you're able to distribute
vast amount of its and distribute it
fairly
and why for example we're not we know
that that ventilators and respiratory
equipment is going to be extremely
important we know this may last for a
year you know what is the global
mechanisms pulling all this together and
accelerating it so it's it's very
difficult for those countries in Africa
and elsewhere then at some of the
poorest countries in the world I mean
they are going to find this very very
tough and it's worth I know our priority
will be everyone here at home of course
it will be but you know we need to
realize that in the end if there's a one
part of the world that manages to get on
top of this in another part of the world
that can't then in the end we're all
going to have to deal with it you talk
about the need for a global response to
coronavirus but at the same time what
we've also seen of course is just how
quickly it can spread across the world
do you think it also shows some of the
risks of globalization to globalization
people that people want to travel that
the migration is just a fact of modern
life and technology joins us up all the
time and only Europe you're not going to
stop that process unless you stop people
traveling to different countries and all
the trade and commerce that actually has
made the the world more prosperous but
what we do need to do and the warning
signs have been there for a long time I
mean after a bola by the way it was very
clear
and Botha was limited fortunately to a
small part of West Africa and we were
able to get on top of it and deal with
it but there were those at the time who
said you know take this as a warning of
what will happen if you get a global
pandemic when you know you get a disease
that spreads very easily and the problem
with covert 19 is that it does spread
very easily so you know out of this for
sure as as well as the mechanisms of
economic coordination to make sure that
we reflate and re-energize the world
economy we should be taking steps that
allow us to have the global framework
and networks in place that if this
happens again and it will happen again
then we're better prepared to deal with
it ok Tony Blair thank you very much for
being on the program as women I think